[Music]  the return of Roseanne and we are  keeping up with the Connors  [Music]  today was the final day of production on  the nine episodes reboot hosts from the  set show a pretty happy family including  this 65th birthday party for Roseanne  who's returning in addition to Roseanne  Sarah Gilbert's back is her daughter  Darlene Oh time we had back from the  dead John Goodman Roseanne's husband the  Becky's are both back  leacy göransson and Sarah Chalke but  only Lisi will play Becky this time  around the whole cast is back that  includes Laurie Metcalf playing Roseanne  sister and friend Sandra Bernhard has  found he's so great Johnny Galecki  returns his David who originally married  Sarah on the show I was so excited to  see everyone in the same room for the  first time in 21 years this is just the  best every detail I mean the carpet and  the tchotchkes on the windowsills it's  like a time machine just  [Music]  you